[Music]
thank you
so Igor thank you for coming on
spectator TV in the magazine this week
we have an interview of Maritza De Luca
which lifts the lid on the hot debate
when it comes to art restoration yes
um so this has triggered really by
um a really
terrible restoration at the National
Gallery it's a pure de la Francesca
Nativity that's had um two shepherds in
the background and they've been
retouched and restored
um in such a way that the garden called
it kind of compared it to the to the
monkey Christ the famous monkey Christ
um from Northern Spain where those old
ladies
um completely messed up this uh Fresco
can you please talk us through The Good
the Bad and the Ugly when it comes to
art restoration the two massive
michelangelos that he he's focuses on in
this book and
um some of those
um
to me to my eyes strike me as kind of a
bit outlandish and
reduces the subtlety and and
the expression the the ambiguity of The
Originals there's these horses in the
convert the this horse and the
conversion of Saul you have this like
lovely kind of expression on the horse's
head in in the original and it's
completely gone
um you have um this complete like I I
find this baffling and it doesn't really
justify it in the book but he he
completely changes the entire layout and
look of Damascus in the background from
what looks like an oriental City to
something that is a Pastiche of a Roman
city which may maybe justify by the
academic evidence but looks just
hopeless
um and then there's also this kind of
very cartoonish
um update
um changing the features of this woman
in crucifixion
um where you know she's sort of in
Fright but actually in the original the
look could be many things it's more
ambiguous whereas in the updating it's
definitely she is frightened it's much
more like a I don't know like a a moment
in a film and then I suppose you were
showing me a couple before we started
recording and asked me which one I
thought was a restoration and I'm a
little bit too scared to say it in front
of you because I'm worried that I will
be shown to have no artistic taste
whatsoever
um but um is there such a thing as you
know uh a work of art that can ever
truly be restored or do you think every
time there's a restoration it will just
lose something definitely you're
essentially recreating the work you're
you're creating a 20th century version
of that work and there is something to
be said in in
in favor of this to some extent what
you're doing is you're you're making it
clear that actually these Renaissance
Works were probably far more vulgally
crisp and far more cartoonish than we
imagine the the the the process of time
has made them really tasteful disheveled
subtle in all the things that we really
kind of respect but actually a bit like
Greek statues which are really like
disgustingly colored in like very bright
quite gaudy colors which I think would
shock us if we did it if we painted all
those white statues that we know and
love suddenly in these gaudy colors I
think we'd be pretty outraged
um but to some extent that brings us
closer to how they would have seen it on
the other hand there's a sort of there's
a lack of modesty in just saying that
you're you're essentially vandalizing
this word often the people who do the
most vandalism in throughout Society are
those who think they know at those who
think they know the the mind and had the
town of Michelangelo right
um so I suppose just finally on that
what do you think uh would happen you
know some of these original artists were
here today do you think that they would
be potentially horrified that the work
was being restored or were all uh do you
think perhaps everything well at least
more people get to see it I think I
think they probably would be horrified
because the sort of academic instinct is
a modern one is is really a sort of
creation of the Enlightenment the idea
that these are their in perpetuity in a
certain way that we we ossify them is um
is something kind of it's much part of
modernity and I think these artists
would have would have felt an affinity a
close Affinity to someone like I mean
the Chapman brothers are famous for
essentially buying up a whole series of
Goya etchings and totally vandalizing
them I mean original Goya etchings
um and I think to some extent I mean I
don't really rate them
um not because they have vandalism I
think you can do good violism and bad
vandalism
um but because at least there's a sort
of honesty to the fact that they're
recreating something they they create
something new and so if DeLuca was
saying look I'm just I think I'm better
than Michelangelo then I would have more
respect yeah but it's the sort of just
say it maybe it is I mean I mean to some
extent that is the sort of arrogance of
a lot of these restorers
um so I I don't think someone like
Michelangelo would have respected that
at all
um thank you Eagle thank you for joining
us today pleasure
[Music]
foreign